[Music]
working that's getting super frustrating
this is what it's like on life below
zero
down tough conditions all around a
filament
no heat no power do anything won't even
turn on and falling too many times
we have balance it's just a typical day
of the Arctic
they confessed what we got the
challenging environment that we deal
with up here in Alaska for getting the
cool shots that you see on life below
zero and we're on the middle of nowhere
and I are gonna be getting some wood I
have a grandbaby coming in and I wanted
to try to keep my grandson nice
comfortable and warm it is just had a
baby so she's bringing him to meet the
rest of the crew a pretty good spot to
launch our drone which is one of my
personal favorite things to do on the
show and chin drum is super fun I love
doing it but it comes with a bunch of
different challenges that are hard to
overcome especially when it's cold and
most of them are related to the cold the
monitor that I use is an iPad and I use
this this heating blanket with a battery
to keep the iPad warm and then when I'm
shooting a drone because it's cold and
my hands are pretty stationary and I
can't take them off in the throw to
shove them in my pocket I use these
fingerless gloves
you need to have fingertip dexterity in
order to do the controls especially to
touch the monitor because it's a
touchscreen monitor I certainly can't be
taking on or off gloves and I also can't
have my hands freeze here are my
batteries which each have a hand warmer
attached to them to keep them warm and
put my monitor and it's monitor frame
I'm trying to do all this stuff as
quickly as I can so that stuff doesn't
start freezing literally wall and
putting it together
I bring believe it or not it's a regular
standard bath mat that you probably use
in your own bathroom it's got a fuzzy
side and it's got a rubberized side that
usually goes down on the floor well this
rubberized side can take off and land on
it with no problems about half the time
we get to this point and the drone just
decides it doesn't want to fly and zero
degree temperatures which is what it is
today
so hopefully it flies and we'll get some
good shots
[Music]
something does go wrong we're in the
middle of nowhere and we might not be
able to get another drone we can't go
down to the corner store buy another one
or get it fixed
even if we have other technical
difficulties it's so we just got to
figure it out on the fly
[Music]
so the drone itself is a really amazing
and unique device for us to get really
cool footage for the show especially
because the terrain in Alaska is so
amazing and vast it really is useful to
show the place of a team human in this
giant background Alaska is amazing and
it's it doesn't get any less amazing
from you know 300 feet in the air snow
tomorrow so I'm not sure we're gonna
make it into camp we're gonna give it a
hell of a try but we're ready for
anything we're going into Quebec for the
first time and Stu's been away for a
couple of months so it's sort of a big
deal and we have to figure out one and
always first the safety of the mission
and so we're flying in with a ski plane
and we want to document our arrival and
our departure so tonight everybody's
putting cameras up and figuring out
where to put the camera trying to rig up
this plane and put these GoPros on it
try to figure out try rig up a GoPro
trying to find a new spot for it here
inside the planes that when sue is
travelling we can get some good shots of
her and good shots of what she's flying
we have to put these little cameras
these GoPros in weird places we can't
only see what's on them so we have to
connect to it phone
to figure out just what we're shooting
all this takes longer than we think to
get the right angle to get the proper
little clamp that the machinist is
making it's good we came tonight we've
got it sort of
[Music]